le renne s'emballe ça qu'on fait
contrairement à ce qu'on pense ça va
très vite un raid
[Musique]
on est partis pour une course de rennes
oui alors les quatre sélectionnés et
ekedi benjamin gille écart ou alors
normalement ça se passe toujours bien
et malheureusement avec nous rien ne se
passe comme prévu on a failli passer à
côté d'un accident terrible oui quand je
dis terrible c'est terrible c'est
terrible pour moi vous avez eu peur où
vous allez oui alors je ne veux pas dire
que j'ai peur j'ai eu peur pour eux
parce que franchement je maîtriser la
situation
comme avec elle ou quoi même deux mois
marie pierre brard une mémoire et il
m'arrive c'est vrai c'est vrai ce n'est
pas ce que je vous dirai ça aurait pu
être extrêmement oui
ah oui oui bah je vous le dis regarde
[Musique]
allez vous êtes prêts à desserrer oui eh
ben on va accueillir la reine des neiges
voilà la règle des nains avec mon benji
beauté magnifique regardez comme nous
ont regardés comme il est beau on dirait
une parenthèse ont fini les conneries
maintenant j'ai envie de commencer ma
course avec mon rennes et celui-là je le
sens bien je suis sûr qu'il est hyper
sympa comme mon père edgar doucement
égard doucement doucement égard
doucement mais gare aux doucement de
gargar doucement doucement seydoux
nerveux bon d'accord égard il a son
caractère comme moi attention 3,2 à
porter
[Applaudissements]
le départ en fait est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus tonique que je pensais pas
ce que ça sa part super vite et en plus
je perds caroline au bout de cinq mètres
le renne s'emballe ça qu'on fait
contraire à ce qu'on pense ça va très
vite un raid ça va très très vite ses
côtés c'est comme ça comme un cheval de
combat à fond la caisse
et là je suis en fait de doha ce que je
regarde où sont les cadeaux je me
retourne et je vois plus laïque de
gaulle à de vue qu'il conduisait le
neutrino est de nouveau disparu donc la
chaire panique le traîneau tourner à
gauche donc je me retrouve tout seul et
je comprends en fait que de lieux à les
soul souple on a failli avoir un
accident avec la cousine de valérie
bénaïm j'ai rien very inqiétude on peut
l'applaudir avant bras mais attention
les quarts full méca foule 3,2 à aller
[Musique]
nous avons beaucoup ri gou quick halal
est en plein jour devant la mort olic la
liste eric castaldi
[Musique]
m
d
[Musique]
non mais
témoigner
je vais
nous on ne va pas non
[Musique]
un port en port
caroline ithurbide gagnant au nom nombre
de cadeaux mais comment ça c'est un
scandale je demande qu'on recompte les
cadeaux on recompte les cadeaux j'avais
bien travaillé je vous déclare les 2 duo
gagnant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]